baby
give my life coming at you
hi I'm Mike mihari welcome back to resin
Knievel I'm here with Shawshank Nick
Masterson it's nice to see that you told
me that was the last one no it's rule of
three I needed there it was Gary
Garofalo a few minutes ago but you were
texting and I changed it just to throw
you off it's Friday
well it's Saturday if you're watching
this but we're recording at Friday at
twitchcon I had oh did I have to I don't
even know what I was doing a whole lot
of nothing yeah probably oh look at this
black bars back you can fix it no fix it
as best I can
good job yeah that's fine I had
twitchcon I did the glitch stage with a
bunch of other wonderful co-workers who
put on content from basically like 10:00
a.m. to 6:00 p.m. was a lots we are
tired I think I got the twitchcon itis
or whatever you would call it right now
you're sick I don't feel great wish I
would have known that I'm fine
so we're toward the end of the game I
don't think we'll beat it today but
definitely by next week probably we'll
see how good I am
reiterate again later but um you'll be
stopping by for extra life for with game
former Game Informer people GameSpot
people did I say Game Informer you did I
was up so early this morning and I just
saw the words Game Informer on the PC
that's okay I do that with my ex
boyfriends all the time
[ __ ] Chad Brad we are you'll be here
Friday 6:00 to 8:00 Pacific but I think
afterward you and me assuming we'll be
done with resin evil which we almost
definitely will read evil zero
yeah oh my god I'm tired we will be
doing a mega episode of which I will do
like a long version right it's like we
normally play for an hour minimum like
on these maybe we'll play for like four
or maybe we'll play for eight hours I
who knows a lot of its based on the
schedule but definitely stay tuned and
pay attention to our Twitter's because
we'll do the reunion Friday night and
then ideally you and I will just go on a
string of like a resident evil and we'll
do like a first episode that we get
which will be really cool the idea at
first was to just beat the game in a
marathon we'll be live-streaming it but
now we're gonna get as far as we can but
we both have engagements the next day
that we can't really get out of whilst
we do this you tell me what I should be
doing because I'm a little confused so I
have just saved I like ended it by
saving you came back here I killed that
thing I do I have these save ribbons
should I've kept them in my pocket cuz I
left them there like where am I going
well you got that elevator lets you
access all now you gotta go back down to
the fourth up to the fourth floor or
whatever figure out where the elevators
might be because there's all these items
in this circle like should I go there
and like see what other items might be
beneficial for me yeah she doesn't does
she have a magnet you should yeah you
used it against the tyrant oh right and
I shot that guy in the Wiener I'm awake
you should bail or keep dodging him
anything I have nothing I don't know if
this is even the way you have to go so
is it I mean he's good he's gonna attack
me what should I do
that guy came out of [ __ ] nowhere so
I was gonna go in here and get some
items all right
but should I just turn around and bail
you out of here and you just started so
you're not losing much if he dies you
must go quick jube quick Juke quick
ugity Duke oh my god
[ __ ] run [ __ ]
oh my god he's so fast
holy [ __ ] I'm like in a lot of pain I'm
probably on like orange caution now yeah
I called it
well there's technically Boise save us
granddad say my grandpappy just died so
I'm flash sorry
hopefully people here like watch Parks
and Rec or that was like super random
jean-ralphio dude Rob and I quote
jean-ralphio all the time I think Rob
should go like his next Halloween he
should be jean-ralphio he'd be really
really bright absolutely hilarious
jean-ralphio combined oh cool so I got
some some Maggie's so I can kill that
guy now or I could just like leave it
but I am like almost out of health and I
don't have any health here it looks like
ribbons and then molotovs take them all
the time all top seem like a good call
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
there you go oh my god that guy came out
of nowhere react l'm eight that scared
the [ __ ] out of me a hundred percent got
me I like I couldn't have been less
prepared for such an event Oh God
all right so I'm not gonna go back the
way I came unless I have to because
that's like death on ice I'm gonna
figure out where the elevator was that
you used the turn thing was it oh it was
near the train there's an entrance there
but I'm trying to member where it can I
go this way yeah it might be a little
longer
and I don't know what kind of things are
lurking there zombie what is that yeah I
see these little feets my own alarm over
here first
is it your left the elevator but yes
hard left
yes oh there's not much every move I got
it what happened they're all [ __ ] up
you were right there's like not a lot of
room to move around let me put my
headphones that gun is this the
elevators it's just the one that goes up
to the roof toys are wait so you're
going [ __ ] I hate health like it's
nobody's business yeah I don't think
this is the same elevator we needed that
one had the option of I can go back up I
just don't know where I'm going mom to
be honest with you I'm not really sure
my objective is I know like my partner
like fell down a hole but I don't know
like I don't have an item like right I
don't have a key where it's like all I
need to go down the you know water to
but I don't know wait where is this oh
[ __ ] come on danger
that sucks the library there's some
stairs over here I could go in there and
like just see what's going on looks like
there's some my guess is those are ink
ribs so I got some ink ribs there but I
got some on me so I don't need those
anyway I could go north and see what
those stairs take me or like again do
you know where I'm meant to be going I
know you're meant to be going to the
fourth floor or wherever it is but I
forget because member we use the
elevator to get off to go save we want
to go to the fourth floor I'm just
trying to member where oh this looks
okay well I'm gonna take these stairs up
unless you give me an idea it's like the
first time in a while that I'm like
genuinely like I have no idea where I'm
going I don't know what I'm actually
supposed to be doing I have very limited
direction in this game right now and
that's fine
cuz it's kind of nice to have that
experience every once in a while is this
where this guy died or fell it's like
where my buddy died yes oh this looks
familiar you wrote the gondola over
what's gone now yeah that cable car yeah
what did you call it a gondola
it's a gondola gondola the emphasis on
the wrong take the gondola wait look
you're Matt maybe he's in the gondola
yeah he's in the gondola [ __ ] oh this is
enough stairs up I might have dunked it
up dude oh it was a hook shot hole I
think you saw the man I don't have the
hook shot you don't need it it's I'm
just saying like am i stuck now like
that I just
you're no you I mean you're gonna have
to go back the way you came I think what
do you mean I might as well just [ __ ]
die if you want to you can get in that
hole god help you thank you are you
staying on danger and like what did I do
yeah I know much I got hate magnum
rounds or not let me actually know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna bring up our last
episode anyway so I can see where the
elevator was I just think I like royally
messed up I mean you can wipe if you
want I'll try to make it back I just
feel like I kind of wasted time and I
lost my entire life like I believe I was
on green when we started this run so I
kind of feel like I exchanged my entire
life for eight magnum rounds which is
not a great exchange honestly
[Music]
I'm tired too
I'm gonna Blizzcon tomorrow I'm excited
about it but like to cons in two
weekends is a lot for marry Emily
Blizzcon didn't start today yeah so the
electron the like the show starts now
and like there's an e-ticket so I have
the virtual ticket so I can watch it but
I'm going more dangerous like see I
gotta use my gun to like kill this guy
exactly wipe you can use to good though
okay so where is he is he like on the
right here's the elevator kill you kill
the tyrant you did good elevator let's
see where you got off
yeah near the Train alright I'll just
let this guy kill me then it sounds like
that's what we've decided yes we need to
go back toward the Train I think there
might be a quicker way but this is the
best way should I get the eight Magnum
Brown yes okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna
have to yeah you just won't have to
fight that hunter I will have to fight
the hunter he's on the way oh I think
you could dodge him if you're ready for
it though maybe
Nathan Shepard says no marry don't waste
mild tops on keyholes please for deaths
102 it's good advice kills and now the
what you want to call it
prototype tyrant got added to that list
cool
dead over 100 bio-organic nasties slain
and then again maybe Shepard has the
disk of people or are you in that this
court I yep people are hitting hit me up
oh I keep [ __ ] out I need to do that
one more a lodge that where did snore
like oh I miss her I have ribs I hope
you do marry I do
alright so sorry just to be clear I'm
redoing what I just did I'm going to go
to the circle and I'm gonna pick up
magnums probably and I have to go all
the way back not all the way just back
through here and then to the mainland I
had to go through him again I could kill
him with the Magnum I think you should
still try to dodge I mean I'm going to I
just like like let's let's think about
this oh that was I thought you got by
him I'm actually in more trouble yeah I
think I got hit three times which is not
great I think if there's a way you can
get around him getting lit from this guy
oh no let's see I bet okay mine is
caution I'm okay I'm not great but I'm
looking I think there's a way we could
have taken a long way around but that
would be I mean if he's in that hallway
he'd gonna get me um should I shoot him
with my magnum rounds cuz I can't afford
to take another hit from him yeah I kind
of have to you open your map I just
wanna see if there is a way around it
like it this way well that's what I did
last time
so like I can go this way but he's still
in there at the area no right I'm saying
there is that elevator
press l2 yeah I wish this showed what
kind of did you're going to the
treatment facility but that's you might
have to go by him it's unfortunate I
would I know
but lake would still try to dodge him I
know dude he's going to kill me well you
have more room now though he's not like
starting off with aiming at you boy try
to dodge him if you can't just kill him
there's - yeah just go that's good
you killed one that's fine Oh God
good job thank you thank you
[Music]
holy hell all right where am I going
probably back into the main hall yeah
down to the that ladder hatch at the
bottom let me change into my regular
Gunson I accidentally shoot his arm with
a magnum that would be a mistake I
[ __ ] had no idea there were two why
what a mean thing to do yeah I didn't
that second one wasn't there on the way
through least I got like a decent chunk
of items I don't know if it was worth my
life but like you know here we are
alright so
there's some other things some Granada's
and what's that that looks like it could
be back yeah great
eight of them great well okay so I'm
leaving yes it is hot here the fans on
rotating oh that was a shadow I thought
it was sweat for a second all right so
now what oh no no sorry no I'm not
outside there's that that hole in the
floor with a ladder that goes to the
Train you're going back to where the
train crashed and that'll elevator go
over there yes of course
where's the whole other side of the
stairs oh this hole oh sorry the square
it's the hole pardon my geometry [ __ ] a
hole can be a lot of shapes because it's
not really about the shape and the fact
that it's a hole yeah it's more of a
lack of okay yeah no well it's just it's
a it's like something that goes down
right no because you can have a hole in
the wall and that goes forward or in the
ceiling
interesting once you're above it and
then it goes down I mean think about it
there was a triangle shaped like thing
and the ceiling you'd be like there's a
hole in the wall like you wouldn't be
like there's a triangle in the wall
you'd still call it a hole I don't know
it triangles a bit too man-made for me
not to notice how artificial it looks so
yeah somewhere around here's the door
the elevator
so this huh so you want to go to a
fourth floor I think okay or basement
one it's one of the extremes I don't
know which I hope there's health around
here I'm like I'm not doing so hot so
you're on level one you want four oh
right like 80% certain
well should reunite with Billy soon get
health
I think there's health lug man
okay please don't have like a frog no
frogs no monkeys no cutscene [ __ ]
William
what the [ __ ] that's like in resonable
six-member the feesh yeah
what is it wait where did it come from
damn it is this the elevator or is this
the elevator okay alright well we're
getting into the sewage I guess holy
[ __ ] wow people are pointing out how a
lot of these assets ever use some two
and three Oh are they the cable car and
this
okay so there's gas I think I have
enough no I don't but I can touch it so
I know where it is what those are the
rules of this game god I could really
use some help
ribbons typewriter police so I could
pick up the ribbons or leave them here
cuz I now have I'm just saying like I
could I have five so I could leave them
and then I would open up a spot cuz like
right like I don't even want to save Oh
with that I don't know what's that I see
it it was like here and my nuts oh
that's the gas there's a gas can on the
other side oh okay dam area power supply
panel designate point to receive power
power can be supplied to any location up
to two points away change points sure so
maybe a good place to start
where am i this square
I'm here oh where I see you're saying
cuz I would probably want to designate
it where I am so I can leave I'm at the
[Music]
oh yeah is that the control room here it
says control room control room - oh
where is that a few of them say that I
don't think well I'm at the I was just
gonna say I'm at the what do you call it
the place where you keep all the poop
just try the middle one so you're just
try to power the whole thing I think oh
I thought I'm so yeah so I can i I can
undo this one or no yeah I thought I
didn't think this was a puzzle I'm dumb
I understand still not getting any power
all right let's try again I have an idea
you want to find the furthest point
right like excuse me like yeah like for
example here is a really far point this
one's hard to hit so there has to be a
point two points away from here that I
need the one and that would be like this
one try the one diagonally bottom-left
because then you'll get this one yeah
but that won't get this one
that's not a pointer one down cuz
that'll get all of these right this one
won't no I'll go too far into the middle
I don't know just now so
here's another weird one where like if I
go here in the middle I'm gonna miss a
lot this is interesting
okay I think you were wrong I think I
did want really likely I think I did
want this one because then it would give
me this corner but I might I mean I mean
I might also be wrong so here are the
issues that we face
I mean let me just do it a couple times
try that see what that does it's been a
while since we've done a little fuzzy oh
[Music]
we're good yeah now do that one yeah
that should be yeah that's two away yeah
we did it okay you're right
maybe there's multiple ways to do it
there probably
good job spectacular
it looks like the power has been
restored
now where is the health so should I save
cuz I think lose to dying and what I'll
do is all over I won't save I'll just
make sure it's a new save that way like
I really do if I am like screwed I can
just go back go backwards if it's if
it's like that type of situation
cuz like if I could do it again having a
full heal or eight Magnum bullets
they're both valuable but I might not
want to give up health in this situation
oh right I mean I hope so
alright so I've I've powered the area
which means I should be able to take
this downtown if you know what I mean
oh yeah I get downtown
that's the Magnum sorry it is no it's
not it looks a lot like the Magnum a but
it's got the sights oh I didn't do the
equip diamond I hear them but I don't do
you think he's I don't I wouldn't waste
the bullet there he is okay kill him
mm-hmm I can hear more oh he's getting
up - that's not good
I hear another one
here it but I don't
Jesus I did not want to go out here
if I was a health I would be here I mean
that's cool but the gas was earlier so
that'll be helpful to combine at a later
time I don't really wanna do that right
now hot mama JAMA
got some heads go should I combine these
and eat them now I did just heal so
shaved oh right I did just save so like
if I died I'm not losing a lot of
progress so I could save it and like
take one more hit but that's also
dangerous yeah all right well let's take
a look at the layout here oh oh that
must be the bottles of course so yeah
this door we good yep okay see if
there's any useful tips in the comments
anybody just saying hey uh yeah
get mall tops yes but I like don't have
a lot of health remember how you think
about this like I could probably take
one hit on caution or two depending on
RNG [ __ ] you handled it well though
thank you
screaming and running away is a huge
skill of mine Oh God
okay all right I think I'm okay yeah
she's the other mulatto oh [ __ ] I
thought I juked him oh no I'm gonna die
I might as well hear with this well yeah
is he not dead he is very much alive he
died well I got two more hits out of
that full heal so to me that was like
yeah good that was like a worthy choice
so I have three multiplex should I go
make the other ones and combine them now
probably yeah
what did you say at 49 minutes last time
I'm curious I don't know I say all sorts
of stuff a bunch of people mention it
and I don't I don't I probably said
something really funny but I don't know
sure sure I'm definitely laughing at
something you said oh you're on dear
number two that's probably why not just
kidding
we did we did drink last episode I'll
look it up in there if I like I'm really
curious okay I have to I have to get
these uh small tubs anyways we have the
time
when the gas is out here and then the
bottles rate
you can read that it off or watching
just watching did I do it yeah oh right
there's just still gas I might as well
leave that okay you stay right there
mister gasps what do you see that it's
fun to watch at least from what you've
seen super fun I would like to play it I
just I got home and someone else was
playing it and I was like alright I'll
observe
it's obviously not as cool but it's
still cool to watch it's such a
beautiful game extremely immersive and I
have just really really enjoyed that
story it's super weird how it like they
didn't it didn't it's not Tootsie it can
be tedious for sure but yeah there's a
lot of like quests like that but I found
if you just commit to the main storyline
you should be pretty satisfied in terms
of controls though oh right I've heard
as well okay so I got two doors here and
I can't take this left one yet so I'll
go straight he's listening to me
I love your passive-aggressive ways of
saying helped me yeah I thought that was
like the point of this series I'm going
you tell me if you find out anything
interesting ha what did I say I remember
that now you've stumbled in the middle
of a sentence and then just said I said
dick balls I should have kept the I
should have kept the gas
so that whole thing is about me saying
balls
Oh dick close enough this is a dead end
oh there's stairs oh there's a map okay
cool all right yes
so I'm gonna go down these stairs I
guess there's a door here no open your
map after you pick those things up I
hope those are magnum rounds oh my god
the [ __ ]
oh cool it's probably weird hearing me
talk yeah well I'm not talking I don't
really like hearing my own voice very
much oh here we go
it's coming you gonna put it in the mic
yes like do I want to do this I don't
know where'd you go what floor I don't
know dick that dick definitely like just
didn't know usually I said derec sorry
people notice yes I forgot anyway
where did Snorlax go I miss her needed
this today thanks Marv Hardy's all right
that's a nice combo let me see where we
are in this room like is this a dead end
so interestingly enough maybe you can
help me it looks like I could lift this
box maybe and then get that item is that
what I'm supposed to do that make sense
it's like look if I'm up here I can't
you probably need Billy to reach those
bullets so that looks like we need Billy
okay let's come back for those then
there's a bottle down there I don't know
I just put it down
no I could pick it up again but I found
more bottles which means the gas that I
left earlier is like you can have
another second round I'm so dumb that's
where it came from
alright let's try again whoops whoopsie
whoopsie girl hey guy um maybe this is
the puzzle oh wait there's a door in
here it's probably this door yeah you
just never know at this game you know
you need to go
where's Billiam Cohen he went into the
sewer yeah he's probably dead shotgun
shells good well I'll just hold I'll
just touch them so that I know that
they're there so I don't forget okay I
don't think I can get over there looks
like there's like water you can raise
that's another door there these controls
regulate the supply and drainage of the
water in the tanks and control the
rotation of the literally resonable to
use this device all right so why do you
need the I can try filling it if it
doesn't work I'll rotate in the guy I
don't know Billy comes pouring out I
feel like I was supposed to rotate but I
wrote you know okay let's rotate right
and see how that goes okay maybe has to
be drained maybe yeah okay [ __ ] I didn't
oh all right so I guess I'll drain it
rotate it and fill it up again and see
what that's all about
do the Hokey Pokey and turn myself
around it's like keep trying this
whatever it is
oh you probably have to try to move them
manually try rotating the other way
first but yeah probably
yeah it's the same [ __ ] yeah I guess so
I don't really understand it but yeah
you're gonna think go down there move
that box come back I'll be rotate it and
then move the other boxes it sounds like
it maybe can't climb yeah push the metal
box this way like if you can climb over
it yeah yeah oh you wait she [ __ ] me
Aidid maybe Nia Billy she's not strong
enough let me see if I can get her to I
was trying to get her to talk and be
like this is too heavy for my like
bitch-ass arms like if that's the case I
don't really even see where else I can
progress because this is like the room
that I need to be in oh wait I can just
keep going alright well I could just
keep going try pushing it the other way
before you leave just I mean that's not
gonna help me are you sure time I hear
right yeah let me try I mean that would
let you rotate this way no she's you
know she too weak
alright I'm gonna take the stairs that I
saw on the map or the door or whatever
go through that southern door and you'll
have your muscle back strange okay um
this one yeah okay let's just do that
thank god you're here I can't open any
jars or push boxes without you that's
not good
Oh does that mean that one of those
thingies are here cuz I I have six so I
feel pretty good about it
I'll just keep one on me no monkeys no
frogs just squid men no cutscene how'd
he get up there she didn't like do
anything he just coughed up that water
you don't want to know what I saw down
there lots of poop in some pee it was
everywhere sue her test subjects in
Marcus's research he must have kept
messing around with the mother virus
wait I'm sorry does he have specialty
vision yeah he's related to Ezio don't
remember ever seeing it she's holding a
lit volatile during this emotional scene
alright so now that I have a boy you can
get the shotgun shell develop in the
morgue all right so this is locked we
need a code of some sort should I look
let me see
it's locked from the other side all
right
well get those shoddy gun shows I hope
he has full health if he doesn't I don't
know what to say Thank You Billy chalk
on chasm bog he's on cotton butts
oh cool he has a full heal and he has a
greener mmm
sweet so he's great he's in good shape
he could eat that herb right now putting
him on green what do you think yeah free
up a space you'll probably need it
people are suggesting you drop
why do we keep the grenade launcher
wait the grenade launcher was in the
gondola room wasn't it can you open your
map just so we know where it is
yeah guys press X it's per room it's per
floor right yeah
this is just the treatment plant how do
I get to different places besides the
treatment plan l2 again oh right thank
you I forgot mm-hmm okay so it's back in
the not in the train I think it's in
like maybe okay so not in here
what what was that translation
laboratory oh no it wasn't lab I thought
it was but we can double-check oh [ __ ] I
didn't it's not a lab factory this looks
promising grappling hook okay
grenades okay it's not in the factory
[ __ ] marry goddamnit the lab maybe wait
we just did the lab oh you left it up no
way it probably goes without saying but
you'll want that for the final boss
fight you wait off that we're about it
now but it's worth damn I wish how do we
not see that when you had to get that
man I thought it was the UM grabbing a
grappling hook I just like I made the
blunt assumption that it was and I I
like didn't even question it let's just
do this puzzle okay so yeah he can move
the metal box okay so you want I said
I'll go alone you gonna push it to where
he is now
yeah open up the map quick cuz I go
alone okay okay okay you want to push it
to where you are now okay so jump in and
then push you got it
yeah now she's gonna have to rotate this
oh I can't even [ __ ] get by they'll
reset if you need to but you'll be fine
oh he probably note before you rotate go
back to him and you might want to get
him out of the way
yeah yes we doesn't die that makes sense
I will switch I promise so yeah I move
that move what the wooden one you want
me to move these to move that yeah
closer to the gate yeah I can do that
like closer to the ladder
yeah towards the ladder I cannot yes I
can no sorry no no no no no go yeah that
well that's fine jump move the left one
down actually you probably moved that
one up anyway
wait I don't know your end game anymore
so yeah sorry if I move this towards the
ladder maybe rotate it for now just
isn't it gonna get jammed yeah it's
gonna get jammed rotate well you can't
do I think left right
[Music]
all right what's my end goal here to
bridge make a bridge Oh - okay so get up
you big dum-dum so I could push this box
over here
yeah and fill this hole and I can push
the metal box to the other way so that's
it that's right we've done it yeah
pretty much
something falling I think you want to
push the metal box all the way up is
that what you been yeah I'm gonna push
this box into that hole and then this
one goes here right
I don't see how else you're supposed to
do this yeah why like in this hole or
you don't know the metal the metal one
doesn't float bowls I know you're fine
so move the wooden one toward the ladder
and then down I can't get it out of the
way what you don't need to
so watch alright so move the wooden one
toward down onto this side you can use
that that alcove or the grate is to push
it can I pull them no are you sure and
[ __ ] this up because I can't push this
box this way oh I [ __ ] this up yeah
that one shouldn't be up there I know I
was very clear when I said that we
[ __ ] it up I thought I could pull
these I can't get behind this box
wait Theresa god damn it
balls right does she have to leave - I
assume like how does it reset do I lose
the game like what if what if the shitty
puzzle is what stops this greatest
nemesis yet greatest nemesis or is the
floating box puzzle cuz honestly if I
can't reset this I'm not sure we're
gonna do oh thank god alright let's talk
about this again
you had them it's I think we just
accidentally pushed that box is that
what right but when you say we don't I
think you told me to and then you were
like ah yeah I told you stop because it
was wrong
let's not let this game tear us apart
it's too late for that okay it's obably
such a hot piece of ass alright okay get
my energy somehow so I'm pushing it this
way in that way correct yeah you don't
really know [ __ ] if I do that though how
am I gonna push this box this is I told
you to push
this is like a whole pushing box issue
here oh wait no so when I rotate it I
can move that one which means as long as
like great so I can move this one down
and then move it left so I think we
can't do that you're gonna move that one
first the black one farthest left what
well you gotta rotate first anyway I
have to wear a tape first I have to move
this what I'm saying is I have to move
this black box oh my [ __ ] god oh
you're right I don't well eventually I'm
so drawn I got it I got confused okay so
he's gonna so here I have to be careful
again here like I just won't talk about
this if I push this in here am I gonna
screw myself over later no you still got
that gap with the great to use you can
jump on the box and then down there
are you sure okay so I'm pushing this
into the wall
yeah just makes me nervous it's not like
one way to do this I feel like there is
now so I can move this metal one as well
but may be careful don't wish it that
way you got to push it up now actually
just push the wooden one left and then
down to this side of the are you sure
yeah okay
jump the metal box cuz like just to make
sure you can jump on these to put your
mind at ease
can you not jump the middle box yeah so
I push it up all the way just to make
sure you can jump jump on you try to
jump on these wooden ones down there
yeah I've jumped on these but ya know
lay hold on haunt on again if I push if
I push this all the way left yeah I'm
gonna jump over it yeah rotate it yeah
I'm okay oh you owe me a push I just
want to make sure you have enough room
to push the wooden one I understand I
don't know how much scary and like don't
want to deal with this
I mean maybe but like who wants to do
this box puzzle again not I you know
alright get down there you know [ __ ]
alright so against the corner yeah yeah
the way rotate know what push push this
to the other side first oh right
I'm gonna have him jump up here and kind
of like stay I just jump down there and
then rotate it left and then riddle me
this how is he gonna push it in oh okay
what yeah so push it all the way to the
wall
yeah and then you're gonna rotate left
again yes I thought we did too I was
about to be extremely upset
well you're the guide this is where you
shine relinquish that roll a long time
ago I'm more here just for I'm just
making sure he's my intellectual comedy
mm-hmm those comedic chops that you have
all right
rotate left oh my goodness this wasn't
too exciting but we did it alright we've
made a purr hedge I hate when they
changed the camera angles when I'm
pushing something assuming you need to
get out of there first
that would make sense I don't want him
in there when the water-filled
traumatized would it would it kill him
[Music]
cool all this pow pow
okay you probably go put that in there
and then save and take it in where
there's one of the previous always had a
door without a handle I forgot to be
honest with you it's back upstairs where
the four little forklift was fort liket
fort licked the latest gaming craze
portlet I feel like if I did that you
would be like you don't have facial I
don't like the way that sounds in my
precious baby ears oh wait can he help
me with this the baby was uncalled for
no you can't do this yet I don't think
it was the hall where you killed that
leech okay got a lot of fighting coming
up just regular zombies probably have
boat right now yeah you probably have
handguns out furball
in here yeah you're so sleepy I know
what's up at 5:00
yeah is this because of the bombs extra
life oh right yeah I hear another one
will you shoot [ __ ] you see how like
not much like she wasn't shooting I
think like I I mean I'd rather her do
that and not waste ammo just annoying
I want more that's the door the handle
right there
okay yeah we can make the exchange
it's gin you go yeah there you go a
little buddy
it's you've seen that Ryan Gosling this
acting range thing that Robin Peterson
yes yes yeah everybody got a sometime
die sometime wow it's the fastest I've
ever seen someone turn a fail it's
faster than kingroot oh [ __ ]
squelching by the way in ocarina of time
was a rude oh no princess weirdo king
zora I think you're thank you thinking
of Naruto um I hear it a thing you
should reload okay uh I don't know what
it is black and yellow black and yellow
they're regulars obviously I come down
here both oh yeah um he's like stuck on
the corner okay I don't know what you
can do about it [ __ ] happening idiot
um what what's going on oh he's on
[ __ ] Idol you idiot
god damn it that [ __ ] sucks he's
gonna get hurt that's right
just move both of them you got right
analog stick action nice
both I thought I could do it oh no start
shooting oh my god we're gonna make some
live for this [ __ ] he's getting a
shotgun bowled unbelievable
oh shoot them shoot them i [ __ ] god
damn it she deal that sucks cuz that's
like a hundred percent like just bad me
you know what I mean like I could have
done such a better job at this make up
for it later that's really unfortunate
shake it off damn it I can't believe
that [ __ ]
I like thought I could Juke them and
then they got surrounded
I couldn't have like I mean it could
have gone worse but I was pretty bad
okay so there's a door here and there's
a door upstairs but I've already been
there I'm confused
let's go in here I guess are you serious
oh no I shouldn't have put her in here
like she's just gonna get hurt
probably [ __ ] you could
are you [ __ ] kidding me do something
god that could have been you could have
lost like died right there he got
knocked down yeah that's fine go he
didn't really get hurt that much though
at all I don't think no but she got back
on the car she don't go through here yet
go um
there's something in the other room all
right but you killed them so that's good
I had no choice you had to yeah you know
but I'm like burning through health
right now that sucks
um go up the ladder in here okay yeah I
got one full heel left I got a spray a
little spritzee but that's it
oh good dude that's like the least of my
concerns
shoot you stupid [ __ ] this is why we're
both on caution shoot I [ __ ] did that
unbelievable
she's on attack she's just trash that
makes me so mad like what am I like what
are you doing she should probably just
pick up the herbs yeah you're right
should she come VIN them though yeah you
might [ __ ] Mary did it again you're
singing man today
the shotgun shells there in the mud I
mean if they each had one it would put
me on yellow caution great there you go
don't you be alive we weren't told a
thing about these creatures attacking us
at the briefing guess they were
surprised in the head honchos to the
things in the woods starting to attack
people but the guards our fellow
soldiers they must be still around well
whatever I don't want to worry about
that anymore uh what I got to worry
about is whether to use my last bullet
on myself or on a friend oh that's sad I
think he used it on himself it's hard to
tell what do you mean like
put it in her use it combined oh it's
already in her making set yeah Oh got
your cool okay nevermind it just come it
just is
now in my mood to go back to where those
hunters died uh what about this ladder
was this that's where it came from
manse that's right yeah no go down the
ladder
yeah go down the ladder see the letters
go down a quick you do a favor they were
in this door alright I hope they're not
[ __ ] there again cuz I am NOT ready
unbelievable you're gonna finish the
game next week for sure
great alright so this room yes but we
have that detour to get the grenade
launcher
what can you won't take that one so
sorry what am I doing here
you're fine in this next room
if it's not a safe room I have to go all
the way back to a previous save room
because I don't have any pucks on me
sweet napalm rounds handgun rounds first
aid spray oh god bless is there how
about okay how about you leave all the
stuff and you're safe for now sure is
there pucks though yeah the fluid used
in batteries is diluted solution mixed
with water and sulfuric acid when fully
charged battery fluid should have a
specific gravity of one point two eight
zero oh my god
all right that's something that's gonna
haunt me where's the sieve well I just
died
yeah it did is there God is there pot on
the bus bless it's always papa I should
tell
it but it made the beep noise that's
weird I figure do they turn off
automatically no we've been in here much
longer than this
that is really weird sweet good job so
we just need to get the grenade launcher
and I think you'll beat it next week I'm
so maybe we'll put up next episode on
Friday so when we start revelations on
extra life it will make sense beaten it
okay that way people have like only four
hours to watch it before we start a new
game
yes so no we didn't wear costumes today
we've been this was like a this week was
crazy but also we are planning extra
life stuff so yeah we'll get more info
out there but GameSpot's extra life
starts Friday and we're going or 32
hours so Thursday across several
countries yeah America UK Australia I
assume yes and we'll be doing
revelations like the first episode of
res new revelations once we meet this
next week will be six ish hours probably
get through half the game we'll just
make that a big episode and then we'll
finish it as normal and then we'll spend
November December the rest of those
months planning in Revelations - yep
hashtag for the kids thank you guys for
watching we love playing Resident Evil
and we love that you guys like the show
always comment and you can just can hit
us up on our Twitter's as well to talk
to us about all things Resident Evil
we'll see you guys again next week
bye have a good weekend
[Music]